الخدمة لها شهادة سرير دبلوم
يا البندقية في الخلف إنها أنا أنقرة
أوها عثمان كفلة الذي فقد جداره
بالمناسبة في رحمك في تركيا
أنا ذاهب للنوم ، إنه يوم جيد أليف
ستصبح ساخنة هناك حتى لو لم تكن كذلك
بالمناسبة خارج الزمن ترغب نفسها
مع سيف الخدمة يكمن حلو حلو
هدف الخدمة
ماذا يصنعون؟
كانت علامة فهيمة مع الطعام لا تزال منفصلة
Emre مثل الأسطورة من الخدمة إلى serci
duolin لي حساب yufkalar ما ولدت
لقد صقل الخليفة تركيا ما فعله
الحق ياكون خدمة الخليفة أنقرة
عشر سنوات آمين 14 ساعة
تركيا مختلفة منطقيا
novavera أن الأرض تتطلب تعليمات أنا أيضًا
وزير خارجيتنا أعطى أيضا
هذا ما أخبرتك أن تفعله
ازدهار وزيرة الخارجية اليوم
الشؤون الخارجية
انا سفير
هذه في أقرب وقت
ليتم إعلانه شخصًا غير مرغوب فيه على الفور
قالت بيلا للجهاز اللوحي: "ستتعامل مع الأمر".
trovalıoğlu المدقع يصل إلى أموال المياه Ati bari
لا ولكن روحي كلاكما
بالمناسبة ، مع Ses Türkiye ، حسابك المريح
مو خزانة العاطفة الأخرى أمي الألم
طريقة حاتم للرب ثمنه
اسمحوا لي أن أكتب إلى قاطع الخدمة للشحن السريع
خصمنا كمال قليجدار أوغلو
ما هو دمير وتركيا في الإخلاص؟
قال لي حتى آدابك ، جربها
داود جوجل عجينة إليف سابيكون
حتى ينهار ولكن يعاد إرسالها بسرعة
أو حلقة TL الرياضية ذات الصلة Osman K
لوحة المفاتيح البيلاروسية الرجل التركي على رأس واحد
لقد أحضر امرأة إخوانه ، هذا كل شيء ، بالطبع ، حادث
الـ mmz الذي تتحدث عنه هو السيدة Mute susannah
هو صديق اخبار يجيت علي متين
نسيج الدبلوماسية لا يمكن أن يؤخذ في الرياضة.
مرحلة النعاس حافة التفاف
في هذا القرن havaturkiye المحدودة
اما هو اسود الديموقراطي فان القانون لا يزال
سوف أكسر مرحاض الكلب تلك الخدمة السوداء
المرشح للتحليل الذي حصل على دبلوم
الكتالوج ليس قصيرا هذه المرة لمن يا عالم
أنا مهتم أيضًا ببيع تركيا إليف
اسأل "إليف" عن القبلة